Mac Pro or Mac Studio I have to do that
again I have been testing these out for
a few days now and in this video I will
show you what you get for that extra
three thousand dollars and if it's worth
it along with the M2 Ultra and the
unbinned version that costs more so
Apple finally gave us this updated
machine and it seems like a bit of a
disappointment and now many people have
said well there has to be other things
that you get The Thermals will be better
this cooling system is insane on the Mac
Pro so I'm going to give you guys all of
that info and my thoughts now this Mac
Studio comes in at four thousand dollars
it is a 60 Graphics core M2 Ultra and
the Mac Pro comes in at eight thousand
dollars it has the upgraded one like I
mentioned but of course that price tag
is for this larger chassis now what's
crazy is that this Mac Studio is crazy
heavy it is almost eight pounds it has
that copper cooling system that is a
couple pounds by itself we tore this
thing down and showed you guys that but
the Mac Pro is such a beast that even
the Box itself weighs over 32 pounds
compared to eight so this thing is a
monster but when you look inside it is
mostly empty which is crazy now it seems
like apple instead of all the leaks and
rumors we had decided to just repurpose
everything there's actually been a lot
of changes in here that I can mention
but even the power supply is a thousand
two hundred and eighty Watts which this
whole system only needs about 200 even
if you count certain cards the power
drives very little so apple is kind of
not caring now there's a couple other
surprises with this setup but first I
want to show you guys the external
differences and the ports now the Mac
Studio has that one fan compared here to
the Mac Pro where we have three huge
ones on the front that blow through this
cooler that looks similar but actually
has a lower attachment point underneath
that chip on the other side we actually
have another fan that is built in there
and most of these just run at idle now
the weird thing is where we used to have
Ram well that has a couple heatsinks and
the actual ssds moved to a section that
doesn't have active cooling coming in
now I love that the Mac Studio has an SD
card slot built in the front along with
those two ports that are Thunderbolts on
the ultra model whereas the Mac Pro
doesn't have that slot they do have two
Thunderbolt ports at the top so I've
often used those and plug something and
sat it down on top same thing with the
Mac Studio it's so compact underneath
the display that we set stuff on top now
on the back of the Mac Studio we have
four more Thunderbolt ports compared to
the Mac Pro that has six on the back so
as is too extra overall we have an HDMI
compared to two hdmis on the Mac Pro we
also have two USBS on both and the Mac
Pro has two 10 gigabit Ethernet compared
to one now for some people that might be
a big deal if you want to aggregate
those or connect different things
because on the studio you'd have to buy
an external adapter now you might think
that the Mac Pro can support more
displays than the studio this thing can
support eight 4K displays with its uh
ports here but no both of these can
support that even though here we don't
have enough ports you might have to do
some daisy chaining but both can even do
six 6K Pro display displays and pretty
much every other capability is the same
you can get the same 192 gigs of unified
memory the same eight terabytes of
storage on both uh but the thing is even
though the Mac Studio has the same ssds
that you can unconnect and swap Apple
only lets you do it on the Mac Pro they
actually sell those separately so you
can upgrade them but they lock down the
studio with that said though for the
price of this Mac Pro 8 Grand for just
800 bucks more you can get the same 76
core M2 Ultra but you can get eight
terabytes of SSD you can get 192 gigs of
RAM compared to 64 gigs and one terabyte
so value-wise that's a big difference
now I was surprised that the Mac Pro one
terabyte model only came with one SSD
card that was plugged in out of two but
when I ran the speed test the
performance was the same between the two
systems so Apple's not making use of
that extra slot they could have made
this a lot faster the PCI Express 4 but
they didn't now talking about those PCI
slots it has PCI Express 4 but like in
our pre previous video what we uncovered
and found is that the bandwidth is
actually limited between these different
slots there's a switcher so that if
you're maxing out the bandwidth on one
for example I wanted to buy this and get
an add-in PCI Express 4 SSD 64 terabyte
card in here to make this a central
server and editing rig well the other
ports are going to slow down or your
speed is going to slow down so that is a
major bummer in a cost savings that
Apple made now yes you can plug in
different audio cards capture cards into
the system and apple said that it can
actually ingest 24 4K streams at once so
that does matter for some people but
others have mentioned that now you can
use external PCI enclosures with the Mac
Studio or other Macs so you don't really
have to have this very expensive model
cost three grand more just to have that
so that is a major difference now what a
lot of people have said is these things
are going to be thermally different the
Mac Studio would be loud and run hot
compared to the Mac Pro which will be
silent that is what I really wanted to
focus on and test out and the results
were very interesting now both the CPUs
are the same we have the same amount of
RAM and the first thing I looked at is
geekbench 6 which is now a much longer
harder test in terms of single core
score the Mac Pro actually beats out the
Mac Studio and this was consistent and
in multi-core I saw the same exact thing
I don't know if Apple was just clocking
this a little bit higher or why we have
that difference but is consistent now I
decided to push these machines to their
limits and I did but first I want to let
you know that this video is brought to
you by Static they have their 360
Universal magnetic charge cable that
makes it really fast and easy to charge
different devices with just one cable
and now they have the snap and go
magnetic charging power bank that
attaches is to the same connector
allowing you to use it with your
lightning iPhone USB type-c iPads and
even micro USB devices and then later
with the USBC iPhone 15 it is small and
really lightweight has 3 000 milliamps
of power and just like the cables the
prices are great get the best price
using the link below and charge
everything with just one cable running
cinebench R23 to push the CPUs to their
limits I saw that the Mac Pro once again
was scoring higher almost a thousand
more points now I also saw that the Max
studio was actually using a bit more
power to do a lower score compared to
the Mac Pro now I did the 10 minute
stress test and I really clearly and
carefully monitored the temperatures
then the fan speeds and the Mac Studio
actually ran hotter hitting 85 Celsius
at Peak compared to 76 Celsius now the
interesting thing is both these ran
completely at idle on the fan speeds the
Mac Pro has one of the fans that runs
slightly above constantly no matter what
but the cooling systems on both do great
throwing some graphics in the mix we
tested out figma which is a 3D design
app and this project was brought to us
by 500 designs one of the best studios
in California zooming in we're seeing
the same performance we have a little
bit of stuttering but refreshing is Fast
and the performance is very similar to
even an M2 MacBook Air as far as moving
around now I exported this high
resolution 12 web pages of this website
and the time was identical on both
systems and this uses some CPU and GPU
so that was interesting even though the
Mac Studio has the upgraded
Graphics now next I wanted to do some
graphics testing so I ran 3D Marks
Wildlife life extreme and the 60 core
Max studio got
221.9 FPS compared to
276.4 so that is a difference of about
25 more graphics performance with the 76
core of course you can get that on the
studio as well but what was interesting
is that the Mac Pro only used about
seven percent more wattage to get that
performance and that once again makes me
think do they kind of optimize the
wattage or the power something with this
a little bit differently and how does
the ultra higher Ultra compare in this
one now as far as temperatures they are
both very low and the fans don't spin up
so I needed something that's going to
push it even harder before we use the 8K
Canon raw export that would max out CPU
and GPU with these new M2 Ultras they do
such a great job that they are no longer
maxing it out now thankfully Lightroom
classic is very optimized now it uses a
ton of the graphics and in fact both a
CPU and the gpus are practically maxed
out the CPU goes up and down a tiny bit
but this pushes the biggest strain that
I've seen in a real world app I exported
542 megapixel edited raw images the Mac
Studio took 3 minutes and 14 seconds
that is blazing fast but the Mac Pro
took the same amount of time there was
literally no difference at all and that
didn't make sense because we have better
graphics in here but maybe it's
something where now the CPU is a bit of
the limitation and you get no more
performance on a system where directly
this is a four thousand dollar
difference twice the price now I also
looked at the temperatures and the
highest CPU temperature we saw was 75
Celsius on the Mac Studio and 76 Celsius
on the Mac Pro Yes actually slightly
higher and as far as Graphics we had 55
Celsius on the Mac Studio and 58 on the
Mac Pro yes it does run slightly hotter
which is absolutely crazy now we made
thermal video of both and on the Mac
Studio you see that even maxing up with
the CPU and the GPU the heat is only on
the back the cooler is incredible in
there and it gets all that heat out very
quickly and on the Mac Pro looking at it
the biggest Heat point was not actually
where the CPU heatsink is it was lower
over here on the motherboard kind of
area and with both fans idle so both of
these systems when you kick them up a
lot and you push it as far as it can
they are silent and they don't have any
issues with cooling now the system on
here is overkill it's silent but listen
to what happens when we max out the fans
manually
foreign
yeah this thing turns into a jet engine
but thankfully this system was designed
for a 28 core Intel that draws insane
power many graphics cards and now it
doesn't really even need it and really
the only fan that's doing something is
that top one here is blowing into
nothing and even on the back we have all
these covers that are blocking airflow
so it's a very weird design and it is
absolutely Overkill so for my thermal
testing you really don't see a
difference even with such a small and
compact design and I believe that this
is really the new Mac Pro Apple Wanted
the old Cube Mac that didn't do very
well got too hot to be a powerful Mac
and then they wanted the trash can that
had thermal issues and thankfully now
that they're making their own chips they
are so efficient especially for the
power that you don't need something like
this even for thermals now of course we
have those PCI slots but because
everything's moved forward a lot of
extra even sound own devices they have
Thunderbolt versions you don't need
those slots and even though you can
upgrade the ssds the price tag is insane
you're way cheaper getting external
storage or getting a PCI card inside of
here so from what I've seen this thing
is Major Overkill it's priced way higher
they just priced it high enough so that
only the people that need it will buy it
and the Mac Studio just is a gem of a
machine and with this being this High it
basically just gets more people to
accept the price tag of this thing and
be willing to buy it and I've already
seen that based off of your guys's
comments so you guys let me know your
thoughts on this Mac Pro we are going to
be making a comparison between the 60
core M2 Ultra and the 76 core now that
we know the thermals don't make a
difference between these and I've looked
at other people's videos to show you if
that extra thousand dollars is worth
upgrading go ahead and click that Circle
above I'm going to be doing a comparison
against my 15 000 Intel version that
would be fun check out that video and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]